[Music]
if you're a big Disney buff and you may
have noticed that there are some crazy
similarities between some of the movies
stay tuned to find out who's passing
Rapunzel may have played a pardon are
you new around here don't forget to give
this video a big thumbs up and subscribe
to the things for more Disney content
now let's check out 10 Disney Princess
fan theories that change everything lilo
& stitch and Moana some movies seem like
they go together
for instance Cinderella and Rapunzel
seem like they probably could have been
BFFs at some point but other movies
don't really feel like they have much to
do with one another one set of movies
like that is lilo and Stitch and Moana
we know you're probably wondering what
in the world for you're going to say to
connect these films well hold on tight
because your mind is about to be blown
so in Moana it said that Maui lived a
thousand years before he met lawanna
so theoretically he could live another
thousand years putting him in the same
time frame as Pluto in lilo and stitch
lilo was late to her hula class because
she was paying tribute to Pudge who is a
God that controls the weather
Maui it's a demigod who controls the
wind and sea sounds pretty similar to us
he's also a shapeshifter
which would explain why Pudge is a fish
are you seeing what we're seeing here
what is Maui shape-shifted in order to
watch over lilo Maui is Pudge just take
a second to let that sink in go back and
watch both movies and tell us if you
think this theory is possible you won't
believe all the connections Jane is
related to Belle there are so many
Disney movies and characters that some
of them have to be related right how
many news stories and characters can one
company come up with you may have
noticed that some characters in Disney
movies look a lot alike take Jane from
Tarzan and Val from Beauty and the Beast
for instance just look at a picture of
those two side-by-side the resemblance
is uncanny this is part of the reason
why some Disney fans insists that the
two are related more specifically people
believe that Jane is a descendant of Val
just stay with us for a second so there
is a scene in Tarzan where Turk is
playing with a tea set not so weird
right well it isn't until you
why's the tea set looks exactly like
mrs. Potts from Beauty and the Beast one
of the teacups even has a small chip
like mrs. hot to sonship many people
believe that this means that the tea set
could have been a family heirloom that
was passed down from self to her
great-great-great granddaughter James
another thing needs to have in common is
their affinity for some seriously wild
love could that have also been an
inherited trait nothing is for sure but
we guess so Elsa Anna and Rapunzel don't
all Disney Princesses seem like they
could be related they're all just one
big happy royal crazy beautiful family
but there are some clues that suggests
that some of the princesses might
actually be related if you pay attention
to Elsa's coronation scene in frozen you
can see that Rapunzel and Flynn are
there now if you were a Disney buff then
you know that tangled is set in Germany
so Rapunzel doesn't live in arendelle at
all that means she traveled
internationally for the coronation
you don't just hop on a plane for
anyone's coronation you do it for family
plus the girls all kind of look alike
Rapunzel and Elsa have almost white
blond hair and who could ignore that
both of the girls have crazy powers
Rapunzel has crazy growing hair and also
can shoot snow from her hands does this
kind of magic run in their family also
there is a crazy resemblance between the
King entangled and the King and frozen
could it be because they are siblings it
does make sense since arendelle is based
in Norway and a Norwegian princess could
definitely end up married to a German
King even if somehow these girls aren't
related we at least know that they all
live in the same world Anna and
else's parents so now that we are
talking about how Anna and Elsa might be
related to Rapunzel we can get into a
seriously crazy theory so if for puns
words related to Anna and Elsa it would
make sense that Anna and Elsa's parents
would be invited to Rapunzel's wedding
because Rapunzel attended Elsa's
coronation with short hair
we know that the coronation took place
after tango the coronation was three
years after Anna and Elsa's parents
passed away so what if while a and E's
parents were selling to Germany to watch
their niece Rapunzel get married they
encounter that horrible storm that
killed them think about it it makes
total sense we wonder if Elsa and Anna
have any resentment for Rapunzel because
their parents pass away on the way to
her wedding there could definitely be
some bad blood there which would explain
even further why the two girls never
talk about their distant cousin Rapunzel
if this is the case then we hope that
the girls can all patch things up at
some point because wouldn't it be
awesome to see a movie with the three of
them Disney do you hear us make a new
movie and we wouldn't mind a film
explaining their connection either Ariel
and frozen speaking of that horrible
ill-fated boat trip it may actually
connect another Disney favorite to the
world of frozen remember in The Little
Mermaid how Ariel was always searching
for human things underwater seriously
the girl was like the Dora the explora
of the ocean anyway during one of her
explorations she finds a boat that has
obviously been shipwrecked how did Anna
and Elsa's parents die again
a shipwreck if Anna and Elsa's parents
capsized halfway to Rapunzel's wedding
then that would have put them right
around
Atlantica which is where Ariel is the
two stories have not been officially
links but come on look at all the
evidence if the boat was in Anna and
Elsa's parents boat then whose was it
and why did it just so happen to be in
the same area where Anna and Elsa's
parents crashed we are just so sure that
this theory is true and who wouldn't
want to live in a world where all the
Disney characters stories are connected
it would be like one huge magical
Wonderland can you imagine a crossover
movie where the human version of Ariel
meets Anna and Elsa and reveals that she
knows exactly what happened to their
parents
would be insane we would definitely pay
to see that jasmine is it just us or was
Jasmine from Aladdin one of your
favorite Disney Princesses as well
escaping the castle to go do her own
thing and she got to be with Aladdin who
was super hot
anyway there are a few theories about
Jasmine in the film Aladdin though the
movie looks like it took place long ago
there is one theory that it actually
takes place in the distant future in the
film the genie says that he had been in
the lamp for 10,000 years but then as
the movie goes on he makes a lot of
references that only someone who lived
at the time that the movie was being
produced would know this leads us to
believe that maybe the movie took place
10,000 years after his actual release
date if that were the case all of the
references would make a lot more sense
that's one possibility but there's also
another the other version of this story
could be that the story never happened
at all the salesmen of the beginning of
the film could have just made the whole
thing up so that the buyer would
purchase the lam we're really hoping
this isn't true because we love the
story of Aladdin that Little Mermaid and
Hercules okay back to the Little Mermaid
if we have another theory about Ariel
and it's really going to hurt any of you
who are somehow hoping that one day
Ariel and Hercules would get together
the two super attractive youngsters may
actually be related if we are saying
that all Disney movies happen in the
same world then the two are definitely
related
Ariel father is King Triton and Greek
mythology King Triton is the son of
Poseidon who is the god of the sea
that would make Poseidon Ariel's
grandfather Poseidon and Zeus our
brothers according to Greek mythology
and Zeus is hercules his father so if
this is all true
then King Triton and Hercules are first
cousins which would make Ariel and
Hercules second cousins so that means
the two of them will not be dating
anytime soon we guess will help to
settle for Hercules staying with Meg and
Ariel staying with Prince Erik even
though we know who the better couple
would be we also wonder if gods have
family reunions can you imagine seeing
King Triton and Zeus in the same room
actually that would make a great film
all of those amazing characters in one
do you believe that ariel and hercules
are cousins
let us know your thoughts in the
comments which is a lot of Disney movie
share similar storylines those lines
being that there is a princess and there
is a witch who is bent on the demise of
said princess the witch characters are
often so similar that sometimes we
wonder if they might be the same
character in fact two witches have so
many similarities that they just have to
be the same person witch witches are we
talking about the Evil Queen from Snow
White and Mother Gothel from tangled
have you never thought about it both
women are crazy obsessed with beauty the
Queen and Snow White actually tries to
kill her stepdaughter because she is
more beautiful than her
mother Gothel stole Rapunzel from her
parents because of her beautiful hair
also we don't know if you noticed this
but Mother Gothel has a dagger in a box
this box looks eerily similar to the one
that the Queen gives the Huntsman to go
kills Snow White
go back and look at the two movies and
tell us if you see the similarities in
the boxes also the women both look very
similar when they turn old if Mother
Gothel and the Queen are really the same
person then that woman is the epitome of
evil she tried to ruin not one but two
princesses lives
Tarzan Anna and Elsa it seems that Anna
and Elsa from frozen have a connection
to just about everyone but this next
entry will really blow your mind if you
watch our videos you will know that we
absolutely love this theory but it's too
good not to mention so you know how Anna
and Elsa's parents supposedly passed
away in a boat wreck well what if they
actually didn't die what if instead they
crashed and landed in the jungle while
in the jungle Anna and Elsa's mom gave
birth to Tarzan unfortunately both
parents did eventually die so this
theory doesn't change the story all that
much but it does mean that on announce
to have a secret brother that they know
nothing about all of this time they
thought their parents passed away when
really they're alive for a lot longer if
this is true there is another heir to
the throne of Arryn
down and no one knows about it instead
Tarzan had to live in the wild amongst
animals and not in the castles that he
should have been born into if this
theory is true then it really blows
everything we ever thought we knew out
of the water
and if it's not true we are just going
to pretend it is aerials mom we've had a
few theories about Ariel on this list
but this is perhaps the darkest in the
film The Little Mermaid
no one really talks about Ariel's mom
much for all intents and purposes it
seems like King Triton is a single dad
to all of his daughters we pretty much
assumed that Ariel's mom isn't alive but
we never really figure out how she
passed away this theory may have the
answer to that question some people
believe that Ariel's mom was actually
killed by Captain Hook from Peter Pan in
the film there is a mermaid who looks a
lot like Ariel this could be Ariel's
mother Athena Athena allegedly was
killed by pirates the little mermaid was
released in 1989 in the film Ariel was
16 at the time Peter Pan was released in
1956 the mermaid in Peter Pan would have
been 36 during the film
if Ariel was born in 1973 then it was
very possible that her mother was killed
by Captain Hook the best the case then
Captain Hook is a bigger villain than we
ever thought it's crazy how the worlds
of Disney characters intermingle and
have effects on each other we wonder
what other characters are connected that
we haven't noticed yet that's it for 10
Disney princes fan theories that change
everything which theory was the most
shocking let us know in the comments
thanks for watching the things
[Music]